so i will say that one of the things
that I used to be pretty insecure about
as an educator so to put it in context I
just graduated with my PhD over the
summer and after spending five years
working on one niche problem you're like
all right well I don't have a lot of
usable skills I just have a lot of
knowledge about this one tiny problem
one of my what could I possibly teach
and so I used to think about that a lot
I'm but something this class showed me
was that actually just the ability to be
entrepreneurial the ability to be
adaptable the ability to be a
facilitator communicator a mediator
between people which i say more all huge
parts of this class was the most
important thing in being an educator
here so it wasn't so much about
knowledge of subject material or
knowledge of a specific skill but just
an ability to facilitate learning which
a lot of the times just comes down to
knowing how to ask the right questions
of what is needed at this moment to help
my student learn and succeed in being
able to answer their questions yeah so I
didn't need to know the knowledge I
didn't need to have to skills but I just
need to know where to find that
knowledge and skills and be able to
bring my student to that place yeah
yeah well no no so I think it's that
this is a you know a challenging
question answer sort of kind of what I
learned in terms of teaching or being an
educator one thing I'd say so I'm a
current i'm currently a PhD student and
so this semester is a graduate
instructor and it was a little bit
unexpected certainly to be involved in
teaching the course this semester and to
try to carry on and extend the work that
Seth teller had done in this class was
to me sort of personally a very
monumental undertaking so yeah I mean
Seth was my master's thesis advisor and
I worked on assistive technology with
him and and saw him teach the class the
first time and gone to the some of the
classes and and helped out in a little
bit in the last two years or three years
as well so to sort of suddenly be a
co-instructor of the class with grace
was kind of a sudden almost kind of
jarring kind of experience a baptism of
fire
perhaps so maybe there's there's there's
three things to say one is it was you
know immensely challenging it is
different from doing research which is
mostly when I'm doing as a PhD student
even you know working on projects with
different people you sort of have this
kind of one level remove where suddenly
as grace is talking about you know
working with students and trying to
encourage them in certain directions and
there's certainly some uncertainty
associated with that a whether they will
take your advice I guess or whether you
should nudge them further in this
direction or sometimes they surprise you
or you know very often frankly they
surprise you very pleasantly in terms of
what they're able to accomplish over the
semester so how to kind of inspire or
mentor students is really something that
that that I learned over the semester I
think a part of this is that it was it
was pretty emotional i guess i think
maybe that's the right word in terms of
the kind of the history of this class
the very personal nature of it i think
we got to know you know our 35 students
very well over the semester and
certainly the clients as well the 11
clients that we worked with and so you
really kind of experience the ups and
downs with with the students over the
course of the projects and that's you
know I think challenging sometimes or
you know interesting to experience
I think the third thing I'd say is that
it was it was it was in the end very
rewarding I mean to see the results and
see students excited about what they had
done to be able to work with a really
great team of people all passionate
about the course so the co instructors
and you know our teaching and lab
assistants who had taken the class
before and really wanted to make this a
positive experience for students i think
in a lot of sense is pretty
unprecedented I don't know if I will
ever do anything like this again for a
fairly long time I guess in terms of
sort of the meaningfulness and the the
challenge and the kind of the you know
personal side of it I think I might be
waxing poetic i guess but i think you
know is really exciting to be able to
put something like this together and for
that matter i think it's one reason to
you know try to share you know kind of
our spheres are full experience release
the things that worked and things that
maybe didn't work as well on something
like ocw almost you know warts and all I
suppose in terms of what we tried and
what was successful what guidelines we
might have to other educators so I think
really the focus of our class or if
we've delivered a good class this
semester and and provide a good learning
experience for our students and our
students have learned and taken away
something from principles and practice
of assistive technology this semester
then I think that's what we set out to
do if we can inspire educators and
students elsewhere who might be
interested in assistive technology or
working in this space if we can kind of
let a thousand flowers bloom when it
comes to assistive technology or the
work that we're
doing then that maybe we've done our job
the semester